One of the biggest culprits in the government staying closed now into week for almost edging into week five
I'm having sort of a little trouble keeping track at this point is Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
Somehow Mitch McConnell has mostly managed to stay out of the news and the headlines have been all about
Trump Chuck and Nancy
but the truth is that McConnell deserves a lot of the blame for the government remaining closed for as long as it has
Because Democrats have passed
Republican bills in the house
Which Republicans could have passed in the Senate if only Mitch McConnell had actually put them up to a vote?
Republicans could have passed bills
That Republicans negotiated with other Republicans if Mitch McConnell had put those bills up for a vote
But McConnell is effectively being a tool for Trump
Mostly though. He's not suffering in the media
He's not putting the bills up for a vote and people aren't even really noticing
Although people are starting to notice after he did this again
Yesterday Senate Republicans have once again blocked a house-passed bill to reopen the federal government
This was a package of bills which would fund the Department of Homeland Security through February 8th
It would fund the rest of the departments that are shut down through September 30th
Democrats Chris Van Hollen and Ben Cardin
Asked for this to be taken up by the Senate and in comes Mitch McConnell and he blocks it and he says we are not
Going to participate in bringing bills to the floor that don't have a chance of passing
What McConnell means by that is that Trump would veto it because it doesn't include any funding for the wall
so they're just not even going to bother but this is playing very coy and McConnell really should be called out for this because if
It's just House Democrats that pass something there's not that much pressure on Trump and Republicans to go forward because you know what?
It's just House Democrats
even if their
Previously Republican negotiated bills if the Senate though decides to debate and maybe even pass a bill to reopen the government
without border wall funding
Trump then is exposed as the reason why it's not reopening and that's bad for Trump because it's the circle
Republicans won't debate a bill that Trump won't sign trumps under no real to sign a bill
That doesn't get debated nevermind passed by Republicans in the Senate
So there's this vicious circle and what's always ignored or mostly ignored in this discussion?
Is that even if from vetoes one of these bills you can still get it passed and get government?
reopened with a veto override if the House passes a bill and the Senate
Passes a bill and Trump vetoes it the House and Senate can do what's called the veto
Override they vote and if they get two-thirds of the house and 2/3 of the Senate to say we override the President's veto
The bill still becomes enacted and becomes the law and in this case government would get reopened. I don't know at this point if
Republicans would come a ward in the house to get the two-thirds
Unclear what would happen in the Senate?
Although maybe it's more likely but this is a joke and Mitch McConnell should be blamed for this thing Trump started the shutdown
He said he would be proud to do it and he did it, but we've got to point the finger at
Republicans who could debate this bill and pass this bill and
override Trump's veto in both the House and Senate if they wanted they are the saboteurs here and
Slick Mitch McConnell has mostly avoided the consequences and stayed out of the news
he really should be in the news because he is almost at this point as much to blame for the government staying closed as
His Donald Trump
One of today's sponsors is privacy. Calm slash Pakman
This is a free service that I've actually been using myself for a while now, and I love it
You just take a few seconds to link your debit card or bank account to privacy calms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox
and Chrome and
What that does is allow you to instantly create virtual credit cards that are linked to your bank account so that you're not actually putting
your real
debit card number on the Internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy things online and with one click of a button
You have the ability to create multiple
Virtual cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards, you can put a limit on a card
So a company won't be able to charge you more than you. We want them to and it protects you from being hacked
It protects you from
company's being hacked which we've been talking about for a while on the program and
It's perfect for signing up for free trial somewhere
If you don't want your real credit card number to be exposed and on file and their app and browser
Extension let you autofill the virtual credit card number into the credit card field when you're buying things online
There are a ton of different advantages to shopping and paying bills with a system like this
Everything is totally secure and encrypted and in some situations
You can earn 5% cash back on your purchases. It's all completely free
All you have to do is click the link under this video to get started and for a limited time
Everybody in our audience who signs up gets $5 towards your first purchase when you sign up using that link below